alright this is the second part of the
tutorial on complex in algorithmic game
theory and we're switching contexts for
this talk and we're talking about
mechanics design okay so I'm going to
present some beautiful results that have
been developed when you look at
mechanics design from a computational
perspective so the plan of the talk is
these four topics and it doesn't make
sense to go through them before I
actually give you the sort of like
motivation for the talk so let's go back
to our you know well known and loved
Vickrey auction so the setting is you
have n bidders and one object each of
the bidders of buyers has a value VI for
the object and these values are private
and the item can only go to one of the
bidders you cannot split the item and
your goal is to allocate the item to the
bar who values it the most so the
well-known Vickrey auction achieves this
gold even without knowing the private
values of the bidders and it works as
follows you ask leaders to submit bids
to the auctioneer a priori you cannot
enforce that what they're going to say
is the truth despite that you treat
these bids as representative of bidders
through values for the item you select
the largest one and give the item to
that buyer and you charge him the second
highest bid now the claim it's an it's
an easy claim to prove it's in the best
interest of everybody to report the
truth there by the auctioneers goal is
implemented through this auction alright
so I'm sure everybody's familiar with
the auction and cool thing it is
generalizes okay and the running example
in this talk is going to be the convener
toral auction setting where I'm going
have n bidders think telecom companies
I'm going to have a set of em
non-identical items think licenses for
broadcasting and each leader has a
potentially complex valuation function
mapping bundles you can give them two
reels the constraints are again that
each item can only be given to one
bidder and an allocation is any
partition of the items to this joint
sets where SI represents the bundle that
goes to be there i sometimes you can
only you can also allow throwing away
some items not allocating them alright
so there are many different locations
and our goal is to choose one that
maximizes the total sum of values for
the allocation despite without knowing
the true valuations of bidders are
priori and as I said and you probably
are all familiar with the victory
auction generalizes to the setting has a
similar form you ask Peters to report
their functions now okay so to report
you the whole function you choose a
partition that maximizes the reported
welfare and there is a way to charge
prices to make sure that the reports are
the truth hence your optimization
problem is really optimizing what it
should be optimizing okay now there are
obvious questions with this format of an
auction first one is horrible Asian
functions communicated to the auctioneer
on the foot in the first step so
evaluation function
if it's arbitrary requires a lot of
numbers to be specified you have to give
one number for every possible bundle and
even if you know there is some sixteenth
way you can communicate your valuation
to the auctioneer the second step could
be hard right so you hoped you trying to
find you trying to choose among
exponentially many allocations the best
one the one that optimizes welfare and
this could be a hard problem very easy
example is maybe bidders are
single-minded each of them wants to get
the whole neighborhood of a node in a
graph and say you have one bidder per
node of the graph now choosing the even
if you know the values you know which
neighborhood needs me there once
choosing the best the amounts to solving
max independent set so that's a hard
problem these are the obvious questions
at their eyes when you want to follow
this format right then sort of like the
the theme in this talk at least in the
beginning will be to go around these two
obvious problems all right so hard can
we reduce communication well one obvious
approach to say okay so assume the
bitter valuation are not arbitrary but
they have structure how can the bidder
maintain two to vm numbers in his mind
anyways right how can he be described by
so many numbers so chances are there is
some sexting description of the
valuations and only target mechanisms
that work with six inked valuations from
some class that's rich enough to express
reasonable bidders now the only road
block then with running visages the
community computational step the other
approach to reducing the communication
to the resort to indirect mechanism
there are two standard approaches so you
can the auctioneer instead of asking the
bidder to communicate his valuation in
the first step he can interact with him
asking him by queries of the form what's
your value for a particular bundle or
given this price
for the items which bundle would you go
after okay so these are the standard
approaches to getting around problem one
and I want to dwell a bit on the second
approach and see what's happening once
you want to design mechanisms that make
queries through the bidders and I'm
going to comment my running example
which was a arbitrary combinatorial
auction setting with the assumption that
bidders are not arbitrary but there is a
modular what that means is that for
every bitter his valuation function
satisfies this decreasing marginal
returns property which says that if you
consider two bundles s and T where T
contains s then adding an extra item to
the smaller bundle increases your value
more than if you added it to the bigger
bundle that's what it says alright so
here's an interesting algorithmic result
due to von drug consider the running
combinatorial auction setting with the
assumption that everybody's functions
are sub modular if you have access to
the true if you can you know if you are
query access to the true valuation
functions right there are no incentives
this is an incentive free claim if you
access to the true valuation functions
then you can in polynomial time in both
number of bidders and items you can
achieve the constant fraction of the
optimal
well fer now the question is what
happens if you introduce incentives
right if when you ask a bidder about his
value for a particular bundle he may
strategize as to what answer to give you
it fall it turns out that once
incentives are introduced all bets are
off meaning for instance here's an
example result if a deterministic
mechanism makes value queries to a
bidder and wants to guarantee a very
tiny fraction of the optimal revenue
which scales with a number of items this
is not a good performance this is really
bad okay so but the claim is that if you
have a mechanism that guarantees at
least one over square root 10 basically
fraction of the optimal revenue and
welfare that it must make exponentially
many queries to the bidder so having
value access to the valuation functions
doing indirect mechanisms of this forum
is not going to help you right you're
going to lose a lot of welfare if you
follow that approach and okay so this is
restricted to deterministic mechanisms
but there are results you know covering
randomized mechanisms the big a bit
weaker bound but this is already pretty
bad and you know also results that even
you know cover any type of communication
with a bidder all right so and this is
some example results there is a long
line of research that actually studies
this problem but the punter line is that
there is a clear separation between what
you can do if incentives are not
involved and what happens in the
strategic world okay so if people can
strategize then all bets are off okay so
you you cannot get push always constant
factor approximation from the
algorithmic world
to the strategic world right and and so
like a pencil is truthfulness
communication and approximation are at
odds with each other and you know we we
need more technology to understand
what's going on and I'm going to mention
some of that technology now let's get
back to the other problem the conflict
between truthfulness and computation
what if the valuations of the bidders
can be described succinctly so there's
no issue with communication again things
that aren't good in general so even in
settings where each videos valuation can
be succinctly described with polynomial
in the number of items communication
still
you cannot get mechanisms that guarantee
a constant fraction of your welfare
these are two example results the fact
there is a long line of research that
started with I believe a paper by
Christos sepideh and singer which
actually make this claim but other
papers that sharpen the claim that
separates the problems that can be
approximated to a constant factor in
polynomial time in the incentive free
world versus those that can be
approximated in the strategic world so
increases notation the class of problems
that can be constantly approximated
called a px is different than a px to
the I see if you have if you consider it
sentence
cool yeah not so the first one is for
the public project problem the rest I
believe are for the combinatorial option
settings right so this is what's going
on with you know the conflict of
incentives computational communication
and it turns out that the world looks
much better if you become a beige on and
so it turns out that you know bass can
come to the rescue to rectify this
picture a little bit and let me tell you
what's going on in the Beijing setting
so for this part i'm going to assume the
same setting combinatorial auction
setting except now i'm going to also
assume that for every bidder we know
distribution f5 from which the valuation
function is drawn and in fact to live
communication issues aside i'm gonna
consider an explicit setting namely i'm
going to assume that a is the set of all
possible allocations that the designer
can choose from and i'm going to
represent ever evaluation function
explicitly the value for its possible
allocation and I'm also going to assume
that it's fi has finite support and see
what you know how far I can go with an
explicit representation of valuations
like this one
since i have now distribution fi the new
goal is to design a mechanism that
optimizes expected welfare in Beijing
Nash equilibrium let me explain the
terms expect it means that I have to
take expectation with respect to the f
is the distributions from which builders
valuation functions are drawn from the
randomness in the strategies used by the
bidders when they interact with the
mechanism and the randomness that the
mechanism may use as a tool to improve
the welfare and beige Nash equilibrium
I'm only going to say it's the right
generalization of Nash equilibrium for
this setting which is an incomplete
information setting with distributions
now here's here's what any questions
about the setting yes no I'm gonna I'm
gonna look at beijing I see ok so for
the upper bounds I'm going to get
Beijing I see for some lower bounds I'm
going to talk about any possible
mechanism so so right some I'm not
cheating ok that's for any for any
interact ability result I'm not going to
assume that it has to be IC for positive
results I'm gonna provide Beijing I see
so here's what's happening once you go
to Beijing setting you know this you
know coolpapers by among others Jason
say the following so suppose that the
auctioneer has an algorithm which given
known valuation functions be won through
VN would output of an allocation that is
achieving an alpha fraction of the
optimal welfare okay that's enough
that's a tool that the auctioneer may
have it's an algorithm that if people
were and strategic would guarantee an
alpha fraction of the optimal welfare
now the claim is that even if agents are
strategic all right for any actual you
desire you can convert this algorithm to
an algorithm that's robust to the
strategic behavior of agents and the
guaranteed welfare is the same fraction
of the optimum except you're losing an
epsilon which you can't in 20 by paying
browning time that scales probably
normal lead one over epsilon so this is
a result that converts an algorithm that
works in the incentive free world to an
algorithm that works that's robust
incentives
and come and and this approximation
preserving namely if your algorithm gets
you know say a half of the optimal
welfare without incentives you're going
to get the same fraction with the
settings
and some since this result represents an
interesting sort of aesthetic for
designing mechanisms oh sorry before I
get to that what this result really
means in the previous notation is that
the Bayesian version of the same class
is actually essentially equal to the
patient version of the same class to
incentives right so but a comic got to
go started saying this result represents
an interesting aesthetic for the design
of mechanisms and that aesthetic is
inspired by reductions in complexity
theory and let me explain what I mean by
that so first of all typically when we
think of an algorithm right we think of
an object that takes as input something
and you know does some computation and
produces the desired output of the
computation in a mechanized assign world
the setting is the same except some
agents provide inputs to the algorithm
and unfortunately for the designer the
agents care about the computed output
okay so they have a keen interest on the
output and if it so benefits them they
may lie actually about the input the
control to influence the output of the
algorithm in a mechanism is an algorithm
that's robust to that strategic behavior
okay so now with this in mind let's go
back to the Vickrey auction right and in
fact the creases also mentioned this the
other day so let's think of the
computation of the maximum of n numbers
which is a trivial algorithm we all did
in I don't know first class in
programming but now let's you know you
know change our perspective and you know
back to my previous slide and assume
that the inputs are strategic
and every agent I that controls input X
I actually has wants to be selected and
has value X I for being selected now if
i run the trivial algorithm every bidder
is going to report plus infinity because
I want to be selected and one way to
make a robust algorithm is to run the
crease auction which is us the strategic
inputs to report how much they are what
they are and after selecting the Box
charging them as well to make sure that
everybody says the truth so as crystal
said Vic reaction is a new max alright
so back to my slides mechanisms are
algorithms that robust to search
behavior and the question that arises is
and connects to sort of like the
previous part of my talk is how much
more difficult is optimizing over
strategic inputs compared to over honest
inputs and the dream would be to have a
black box reduction from mekinese design
to algorithm design for any optimization
problem what I mean by that so suppose
we know an algorithm that works well on
honest inputs what we'd like to do is to
sort of like come up with this other
algorithm that interacts with agents and
can also query this algorithm to get
information maybe about the problem and
sort of like you know after baby several
rounds of interaction with the engines
and the algorithm during the algorithm
to into various inputs and getting the
responses produces an output in such the
way that this whole scheme is robust to
the strategic behavior of the agents
and if I interact this algorithm just in
an input-output way without looking
what's going on inside the algorithm
knots a black box reduction so why would
you like such a black box reduction
between mechanism algorithm design well
first of all more is known at least in
the TCS community about algorithms and
mechanisms so you would hope that some
unsold mekinese design problems would
map to algorithmic problems that have
already been solved the other reason is
that such reductions would allow larger
community to tackle important problems
in mekinese design by leveraging their
knowledge of algorithms and without
necessarily any game theory to do that
and in the end of the day having such a
reduction would provide a deeper
understanding of mekinese design giving
information about what makes incentive
difficult to deal with okay so with this
sort of like grant goal in mind let me
go come back to this result and say that
actually the reduction that they provide
is black box okay that don't need to
understand the inner workings of the
algorithm they're using okay all they
need is query access okay so they want
an API now to an algorithm that solves
the problem in a incentive free world
and interacting with this algorithm just
on an input-output basis they can
convert it to something that's robust
that's a very general result for welfare
optimization in Beijing settings and
there are some precursors in the nan
Batian setting that I'd like to mention
as well before I go on so a beautiful
result by love in Swami shows that in a
vision in a nan Batian world in the nan
Batian setting if you're the welfare
problem you're trying to solve can be
written as a config you can be
solved by a configurational p that would
produce a fractional solution together
with the rounding algorithm then with
black box reduction to the rounding
algorithm you can solve the same problem
get the same factor approximation factor
in the strategic setting this is not as
general as this but it says that if the
welfare problem you solve it has a
particular structure and can be solved
by particular type of algorithm then
with black book access to this algorithm
you can make it strategic robusta to
start the strategic agents another
dessert in the in the same vein is the
following that if your welfare problem
is a packing can be expressed as a
parking problem and sorry for the
economies in the room if these are
unknown worlds where it's I'm not giving
the definition but let's say that I'm
going to give you a flavor of this
results if you don't know what these
words mean if you're a problem you're
you know incentive free problem is a
packing problem and can be solved to
arbitrary approximation in polynomial
time then with black box access to the
algorithm this this polynomial time
approximation scheme you can convert you
can you can solve the the strategic
problem to arbitrate approximation also
in polynomial time so these are these
are just two examples of black box
reductions between mechanism and
algorithm design any questions so far
so so be it's okay so all these results
apply to welfare and other objectives
such as revenue are not well understood
with young and Matt we're both here and
we'll spend the semester here we got in
the intubation setting we got a general
reduction from mechanism to algorithm
designed for any optimization problem as
long as you put the right qualifications
here i'm going to show you the flavor of
the reduction but just an example
corollary before i go on as a corollary
of this reduction we get that there
exists for normal time computable
revenue optimal mechanisms for additive
bidders which extends the celebrated
paper of margin to multi out of settings
in fact it can accommodate various
features like budgets or in fact you
know can go beyond additive bidders and
beyond the objectives of welfare and
revenue that are well-studied now also
by using this basically purely
algorithmic result we also get
structural information about the optimal
auction and are also going to give a
flavor of what we get but before I sort
of present this result let me give a
pointer to the talk of Christa's Jamil's
in the complexed in simplicity workshop
where he's going to talk about how you
can use optimal transport theory to
characterize the structure of the
optimal action even better tighter or
you can see a surveyor out for the past
cigam exchanges volume relevant let me
give you the flavor of this reduction
and again what I want you to have in
mind is this picture because now i wanna
state
general i wanna i want to state the
mechanist design problem in the most
general way and related to a
corresponding algorithmic problem and
provide a reduction between the two
problems okay so so I claim that a very
general mechanized assign problem looks
as follows you have some input set X and
some solution set s and you also have an
objective function oh now the objective
function Oh we'll get an n-tuple of
inputs together with a proposed solution
I will tell you how good the solution is
for that end tapal of inputs that's a
general way to describe an optimization
problem and this is going to be a
mechanist design problem so I'm not
going to have the inputs directly but
i'm going to have access to strategic
agents 1 through n such that it's agent
i knows the realization of the i'th
input but this is private to him and I
don't know it I'm going to have a
distribution from which start input is
drawn so that makes the setting vision
and what is interesting and this
captures the fact that the inputs are
actually having it's a mechanism problem
so the inputs have a keen interest on
the output of my computation the these
inputs are both inputs to the function
that I'm trying to optimize but they're
also functions themselves right and this
is how much they like its solution okay
so that's a general way to phrase a
mechanized assign problem right so this
is the auctioneer's the designers
objective that cares about the realized
inputs of the bidders and wants to
choose a solution and allocation for
example to you know maximize that
objective to make the score as high as
possible on the other hand each input
cares about the solution that the
designer chooses of this
is also a function that tells you how
much that be there likes its solution
does it make sense the abstraction yeah
your designer might care about the
expected value ejections so I'm gonna
get heart wise thing but you couldn't
betray us between the iphone let's do so
so this is this yeah so the goal of the
designer is to optimize the expected
objective value and what I've written in
this slide is that he wants to find a
truthful mechanism that's not necessary
maybe you want non truthful mechanism is
to optimize the expectation of your
objective for the expectation is over
the distributions and anything else that
surround them in your setting yeah I'm
going to insist on truthful mechanisms
because it doesn't help me but so this
is a general way to abstract this weight
abstract the mecca and mekinese design
problem the corresponding algorithm
design problem is basically the same
right except so you have the same set X
as an objective function except now you
know the inputs you know exactly sorry
yeah looks like standard
will usually have some notion of
individual rationality constraint as
well as a second how did Billy you've
got keen interest yes yes yes I guess I
don't bleep it what kind of visual
rationality same so you could actually
do that as well it's in here I didn't
wanna yes so you want you want to design
a mechanism that were you know where
agents will truthfully report their
inputs and also will come and
participate in your mechanism so all
these constraints are here I'm just
abstracting the wrong way from is my ass
is because there are different versions
of this will company in literature
there's ex ante in a room and expose to
visual rationality gob come to meknes
hikes post okay if you like yes but you
can choose if you want X auntie I'm
happy to accommodate but or if you don't
want individuals and algae I'm also
happy to come with it but it's like to
know yes yes no it's a good question so
so on the algorithm design side the
problem is the same except now you know
the inputs so there's no question about
both the inputs are and what you want to
do is you want to choose the solution s
that optimizes the how good that
solution is for those inputs I what I'd
like to get is a reduction from this
problem to this problem because
obviously if you can solve this problem
you can definitely solve this problem
because maybe the distributions are a
point wise all right so this is a
special case of this problem so maybe
you just exactly know the valuation of
everybody they put a weber agent so if
you are able to solve this film
definitely you can solve this problem
question is if you can if you have an
algorithm for this problem can you also
solve this problem then I want to get
the generic reduction from the left-hand
side to the right hand side yes
because like something like under the
the progress is device aboard so later
and call you you need a solution like so
let each person is prayer up in my
somehow up reminded strategy
individually they can inflate and you
know who all which is some of the most
apartment optimal solution magnetic you
don't need up because in this
description if you didn't mention any
other assumption right so there is still
very amazing or we now some intuition
why this can't always be I'll try to
give ya so in the next slide I'll try to
give some intuition about why they
seduced but first of all let me say that
this the such adduction doesn't exist
okay alright so you would like to have
this interaction but it does not exist
as a result by Charlie Moore link and
Lucy are saying that though you know so
maybe you know sometimes you can solve
this problem but it will take you a lot
of computation to use this algorithm to
solve this problem so this you cannot do
but what you can do is you can perturb
this right-hand side a little bit and
make the reduction possible so the
perturbation that we propose is to
change the algorithm the algorithm
design problem to take to have actually
two objectives one objective is the
original objective the other objective
is a linear cost function it's a welfare
okay so we take that objective from the
mekinese designer and we change it to
the same objective plus welfare now the
input is we have two inputs okay inputs
X I like over here but also input why I
so not defined so this is a well-defined
problem now right so this is a well
define algorithmic problem it takes a
simple to know X as 0 2 tuples of inputs
I want to optimize the objective all
plus welfare so we would change the
problem of the side
right now the exes come from this is
from the original set the wise come from
the same set the closure of that set
aren't a linear operations that's that's
why I have this plus minus here alright
so this algorithm pro is related to that
but it's not the sort of like the
deterministic version of this problem
because i have changed my objective to
add this feature well this well fer term
yeah so forget about what I've talked
about then just look at this problem
right this is a well-defined problem it
says I give you two tuples it's just a
function that takes to n inputs instead
of just n inputs right and the objective
is the original one plus welfare so if
you look at this thing it's a welfare
function right because you some of our
agents how much the agent likes the
solution so that's a welfare function
this function remote eh it's whatever it
is it could be revenue it could be
welfare it could be makespan it could be
whatever the designer is trying to solve
functions so Lena yeah so it's it's a
same set with linear closer yeah how do
you find why I y sub I office this is
this is a space of functions right and
this is the closer of that certain under
linear operation so these are also
functions so this is well defined right
so since X is since this set contains
functions all right so yeah yes ok I
said X is properties very accessible
evaluations X plus minus is what it's
not so much love relations and that's
important yeah it is not I don't know
what it is yes but so if this is oddity
valuations this remains our evaluation
since I can say ok but if it's for
example submodular this is not submerge
dealer cousin I don't know actually it
could be questioned but we also its
discriminatory work for anyone could
have my nizzle yeah so we call it which
on one phone
taken lagrangian of sorts hey you're
pushing the Saladin
we're not doing that but I believe there
is a way to think about it this way yeah
so let me state the result we obtain a
polynomial time blackbox reduction from
for any objective that you care about
from this side to this side in other
words if you have an algorithm for this
problem then putting through our
reduction you can get a polynomial time
mechanism for the original problem it's
also approximation preserving if you can
only alpha proxima this you can alpha
proxima cat and the techniques are
basically hinge upon two things so one
is using the part of the ellipsoid
algorithm the other part is to use
borders theorem that Jason talked about
today earlier today and in fact extent
borders theorem to multi multi item
settings and okay so I realize that this
is an abstract theorem and now I want to
instantiate what's going on in a very
very trivial setting yeah equivalence um
is it the case that super fun on roof
not not always but not always yeah
so I want to instantiate this abstract
frame for setting the very simple case
that we already know how to solve i'm
going to have one item and bidders and
HP there i will have some scalar now
value in that belongs some set VI and is
drawn from some distribution fi both the
distribution and the set are known the
reales value of the bigger isn't done so
it's a bayesian setting and the goal of
the of the of the auctioneer is to
optimize revenue and what I want to do
is I want to formula so we know how to
solve this problem we can run Madison's
auction but what I want to do next is
that wont to formulate the problems that
combinatorial optimization problem
instead of doing analysis ok so so I'm
going to see that everything is finite
so the support of this thing is finite
and one way to optimize over mechanisms
is to actually optimize over-allocation
and price functions so and in the end of
the day a mechanism is a mapping that
takes as input the reports of the agents
and decides with what probability to
give the item to each bidder and it also
takes a bunch of reports and decides how
much to charge every bitter okay so at
the end of the day finding the optimal
mechanism is nothing but looking for the
best allocation and price factions
right so the mechanism that i'm trying
to find will ask bidders to report their
values given the reports it will
allocate the item to be there I with Rob
ability X I and charge mpi and both of
these are functions of the reports of
everybody now have to make sure that my
mechanism is feasible and that be
guaranteed by this constraint which says
that no matter what the reports of the
bidders are if I some the allocation
probabilities I don't exceed one I also
have to make sure that bidders I'm
looking for a truthful mechanisms I want
to make sure that bidders are not going
to miss report their values and this
constraint captures that because ok so
the quantification is for all pairs of
possible values for bidder I and what's
happening here is that bitter i thinks
takes an expectation with the values of
the other guys and he's interested in
the probability that he's going to be
allocated the item if he reports VI in
which case his expected value would be
this the product of the probability and
his value and he's going to be charged
this price ok and that both of these
depend on the other people's report and
he's taking an expectation over them
he's comparing the expected utility with
what would happen if he instead
misreported his violence at VI prime ok
and what this constraint says is that
for every possible values he doesn't
want to do that ok that's the standard
thing so and the expected revenue is can
also be written as a linear function of
my variable so in the end of the day
everything that I need to express my
objective which is the expected revenue
as well as the feasibility constraint
and the inside of comparability
constraints they're all linear
constraints in my variables so this is
an LP that I can solve so finding the
optimal megan is just an l
but the issue is that this LP has too
many variables right so I have a
variable for I have two variables for
every possible report by the other
bidders so if every bidder has T
possible values that the number of
variables is exponential in the number
of bidders which is not something you
can accommodate so the proposal
interesting proposal you know you know
used in the mekinese design literature
is to look instead study interim
allocation rules Anita demarcation rule
is what Jason was talking about except
Jason described in terms of quantiles
and I want to describe it in terms of
values so here's the definition so they
in turn him a location to be there I
when he reports a particular value is
the expected probability by which he's
going to receive the item if he reports
that value in expectation of what the
other guys are going to say ok that's
well that's all it is right and
similarly the interim price that be
there I will is going to pay if he
reports via is the expectation of what
the other guys are going to report of
the price is going to pay now the
motivation for this definition is that
if we look at the second and constraint
of this constraint the Beijing self
compatibility constraint and take
expectation through right we really
recover the interim rule here right if
this expectation goes through here I'll
get the interim rule over here and the
interim price over here so this
constraint really only cares about
interim allocation so not exposed
allocations which are here similarly the
revenue only cares about interim prices
right so the motivation for these two
definitions is that at least these two
constraints only care about the interim
description of the mechanism
so taking expectations what's going on
here yeah taking expectations through
these two constraints become just linear
constraints in the interim rule not only
the only trouble with using this interim
rule instead of the ex post rule is that
the first constraint cannot be expressed
easily in terms of the interior
description of the mechanism alright so
the first constraint says for every
possible vector of reports the sum of
probability of allocation probabilities
should not exceed one because I have one
item but this is hard to express in
terms of the interim rules so I have to
find a way to express this constraint in
terms of the variables that I'm
interested in the reasonable use these
variables is that these have polynomial
description in the size of my problem so
let's let's dwell a bit on this and look
at an example so suppose I have two
bidders and their values are drawn from
this side for for bigger one ABC
uniformly randomly and for the other
bidder from the set d e f so these are
the two values rather it randomly the
two sets now let's try to see ok so
somebody proposes the following interim
allocation rule to us and we want to
decide if this is feasible namely if
there is if there exists an ex post rule
that induces this interim rule ok how do
you say say is it feasible or not
so it's not obvious whether it's
feasible or not but there's you know we
can consider like work our way through
and see if it is so for instance we see
a one here this one says that if be the
one reports if be the ones type is a
then no matter what else happens no
matter what this guy says he has to get
the item all right so whenever bigger
one reports a he has to get the item
otherwise this constraint would not be
satisfied this constraint says that
whenever one says a he has to get the
item with probability 1 no matter what
the other guy says so this is forced
whenever the reports are a and anything
I has to win I feel if I make this
assumption and I'm forced to make it
then there is a suspicious to over 33
over there right now d has already
consumed one-third probability against
the name so we better give him the item
against BMC so whenever the reports are
being c vs d now d has to get the item
and now we make this concern satiated so
these two are happy let's say about this
other two guys well since this is a 0
whenever we have B and F we can
comfortably give the item to be and we
get at least a third right because this
event happens with probability a third
similarly whenever we have see any we
can give it to me and now this guy sorry
this is a to this guy gets also at least
a third but these guys require more
right and we have to decide what happens
when they appear against each other and
it turns out that to satisfy these two
numbers you need in this case to
allocate the item probability one-half
to be and two-thirds to e which is
certainly not possible so working our
way through this example is false that
it's infeasible
to satisfy this constraint any questions
about what happened here of the
definition of interim rules
there is a bit hard to work your way
your head around the integral because
it's taken an expectation over what
happens outside of this bidder so that's
what makes it hard but this is already
hard to do like and we're lucky here
because you know we have this we had
this one that helped us
we have issues
but what full screen
that's my family
ok
yeah so all right so in the previous
slide oh come on okay the prettiest lady
we were happy lucky because we have this
one that forced our way through this
example and these two thirds but in
general it's hard to check if an interim
rule is feasible all right so the
question is is there a you know easy way
to check whether you know an interim
allocation rule is feasible and board
starting with border and follower papers
we got a very nice characterization of
when an interim rule is feasible Jason
showed it in some way I'm going to show
it in another way an interim rule is
feasible if these constraints are true
so now let's try to read them so we want
that for any subset of the possible
values of each of the bidders so this is
a collection of subsets of possible
values we want to have that this small
Oracle than that now let's read this
thing so this sums of our bidders some
sort of our values in the selected set
the probability that bid arise values VI
and conditioning on that getting the
item so this thing is the probability
that the item goes to some bidder whose
value was sampled inside this set that
we chose on the right hand side that's
easier to do figure out is the
probability that there exists a bidder
who's sampled value is inside the set so
clearly if the rule is feasible it must
be that this is Mallika than that but
for any selection of sets what the
theorem says is that this is a new phone
on leave all right so this is borders
theorem and you shouldn't be surprised
by it if you know Mark flow min cut and
you know in fact Jason's proof in the
morning was a max flow min cut proof
again these are too many constraints
because if I were to add this constraint
LP I will have to take it for all every
possible subsets of types for every be
there are too many constraints and what
young and I proved and independently
Allah a tell is that in fact you can you
know choosers so we showed that they can
choose a small subset of this concern in
this suffice for feasibility so not
liking this constraints to the LP i have
before i have a polynomial size LP and i
can find the optimal mechanism that's
basically how things get this conveys
help you change valuable use exactly if
i didn't have these concerns i wouldn't
be able to express this as a linear
constraint but now i can't of course
this was just single items yes I used
that additional winner Social Welfare
them here or there wasn't no I didn't I
I haven't shown you how this is used yet
I'll show his gets in a little bit so
this is single item feasibility and this
was the workhorse in JSON stock but it
doesn't always work for
multi-dimensional settings multi-item
settings it was used in json to
understand some multi-dimensional
settings but it doesn't work always and
just to give you like a hint about you
know what's the difference between a
general multidimensional setting and
what Jason was talking about consider
these two settings one is you have two
bidders to Mercedes cars that are that
can be painted either red or blue versus
you have two bidders and two cars one is
a Mercedes and what is Alexis and you
cannot paint the Lexus to make it a
Mercedes so the difference between these
two settings is that in this setting the
allocation rules are any single
dimensional so you can use borders
theorem to design optimal
multi-dimensional mechanism so it's a
multinational setting because bidders
have different values for red and blue
nevertheless the allocation rule is
single dimensional because basically
have two Mercedes right and you can
customize them after their are located
in this setting you have a
multi-dimensional a location constraint
so this is not covered by border it
needs more technology the pertinent
question is okay so you have to come up
with some interim rule to describe even
multi-dimensional settings the question
is what information you need to maintain
in this interim rule and the obvious
approach is to do to generalize what I
was doing the single item setting so
what you can do is for every be there I
for every possible now valuation for
that bitter because we're in a
multi-item world for anybody I and for
every possible valuation function for
that bidder and for every item J you can
maintain in your interim rule the
probability that item J is given to be
there I when he reports this valuation
function that this is the immediate
generalization of the single item
interim rule I was talking about and the
question that arises is is this a good
enough information to maintain in a
multi-dimensional world and as you
probably guess it is good only in the
very special cases for example additive
or unit demand dealers because if a
bidder is additive and he is summing the
values of the items in the bundle you
give him then if you know the interim
rule you can exactly understand his
expected utility if you expected value
because you can take an inner product of
these probabilities with a value with
the vectors of values of characterizing
his inner audit evaluation but it's not
true in general so he hears a trivial
example so suppose you have a bidder who
wants to a pair of shoes for ten dollars
he doesn't care about getting either a
left or a right shoe and consider two
mechanisms to a
occasions one is your locate both shoes
to the bidder with Robin via half vs.
yellick at arundel shoe to the bidder
now if you think about it the interim
allocation probabilities of these two
allocation rules are exactly the same
but that's not enough information for
the bidder to understand how good this
interim allocation is for him unless he
sees the fully fledged allocation
exposed allocation rule so if I'm
committed to working in the interim
world I cannot get away with just
maintaining marginal allocation
probabilities of each item to the bigger
yes / unit demand yeah but this example
would work equally value in command yes
there's nobody try you all right yeah
that's an excellent question and maybe I
shouldn't be saying that but you need
the money is to handle by pushing this
constraint to the allocation rule you
can you can push it somewhere else but
the right but then I think additive
economic interpretation
yes you were going to make it exposed
best for me right if it was clear to the
bidder what these probabilities mean
that if it was clear basically want a
way to go from interim allocation
probabilities to expose probabilities
over bundles if you have a canonical way
to do that you good of course you could
be more explicit and maintain in 30
medication probabilities overall bundles
but that's too expensive and instead
what we do is we are actually not
literal about allocation rule we forget
about allocation probabilities and
really what we maintain is this funny
thing that we call interim swap value
function which basically says in
expectation of what the other bidders
are doing what would be my value if my
real valuation function was VI but
instead I said VI prime to the mechanism
this is an arbitrary definition that is
not another nothing to do with an
allocation it's you know the allocation
maybe is very pleasingly hidden behind
this but what we show is they can
actually write a polynomial size LP in
terms of these guys and you can solve it
to get a mechanism this is at a very
high level what's going on I coming back
to this picture basically what's going
on is that yeah sorry right I mean you
clearly wrote that at least exponential
size after you like never were I IV I VI
prime there many VI said many times so
you having
yes I'm work yeah so I'm working right
so I'm working in the setting i
mentioned the beginning the distribution
fi has finite support and that's part of
my input I'll tell you in a second ok so
the importance of this result is to get
rid of the exponential dependence in the
number of bidders which is not here yes
is this where right things instead of
interim allegation rules allow you to
handle correlation yes we can do it we
go we have some results about that yes
we we cannot be done up yes so the
answer you can write something like this
to handle correlation we have not we we
have not really seen if you can use it
to get mechanisms but you can use this
approach to handle correlation but this
shouldn't be with respect to yourself
but also other bidders right so it has
to be something about other bidders in
the interim rule
so I can we go back to this very high
level picture here's the high level
sketch of the proof you write the
polynomial size LP using this interim
swap values again your issues that fizzy
built is hard to check it's hard to
understand given an interim swap value
function whether there is a mechanism
that induces that swap function and what
we want to do is want to develop a
separation Oracle for this problem so
that we push it into an ellipsoid
algorithm to solve our LP and it turns
out that if you study this problem
really really hard the separation Oracle
you need a algorithmic problem you face
to develop the separation Oracle is
exactly this thing so that's how this
problem gets related to mechanize design
all right so you want to solve this
mechanized assign problem you write it
as n LP you have to make the LP succinct
so you resort to using this interim
objects now you have to tell you have to
be able to tell if an interim object is
feasible and if you work hard you
realize that the algorithmic bottleneck
to getting that to solving that problem
is exactly this problem which looks
similar to that so this is how we got
the reduction
and an important byproduct is that note
with not not just get polynomial time
computable mechanism but we get some
structural understanding of the
mechanism so in this setting of revenue
optimization with multiple items and say
unit amount bidders the mechanism
suspiciously similar to my recent
auction the mechanism is to ask bidders
to report their value for its of the
houses we then transform these reported
values to virtual values using some
mapping from values of virtual values
and then after that we find a max weight
allocation like Marcin does charging
prices to make the whole scheme truthful
so this is I feel familiar with Madison
this is very similar to Marcin the
difference is that we don't understand
the virtual transformations very well
their output by the ellipsoid algorithm
and they randomized in the world of with
Alan deckle bomb and Chris's Jumbo's
that I mentioned we provide you know a
partial answer to how these
transformations look like and let's see
so for the last sort of like to slide
part of my talk I'm coming back to
computation and asking the question does
Beijing so babe asian assumption helped
us in InDesign getting these reductions
from mechanism design question is does
it help us also reduce communication
we've already seen that in a nan Batian
world these things are in conflict so
question is does bayswater help so
result also mentioned by Tim on Monday
in this vein says that consider Beijing
combinatorial auction setting with sub
modular bidders and instead of doing
anything complicated like VCG suppose
you just run simultaneous first price
auction so simultaneous second price
options the result is that in base Nash
equilibrium these auctions will give you
a good fraction of the optimal revenue
so the Beijing assumption helped here as
well so you got mechanisms that require
you know minimal communication with the
bidders and guarantee a constant
fraction of the optimal revving of
course the world is not exactly as good
as it looks because there are
computational lower bounds saying that
the base nash is good but it's actually
hard to find in some settings
nevertheless this is another very nice
result in this area there are ways to go
around it so feldman gravely loose
you're very recently I've shown that
there exists a sequential posted price
mechanism that guarantees a half
fraction of the optimal revenue in a
Beijing setting and this megan is
basically trivially truthful so bidders
come after the other one after the other
and select the best bundles out of the
remaining bundles subject to the prices
that are there so basically helps in
communication and communication and but
this sort of like is an interesting
point to mention a very interesting
simply
versus complexity trade-off that is
important for mekin is design and in
fact is you know it's part of the title
of the second workshop this semester so
clearly if you have a simple mechanism
with obvious equilibria this is a great
thing ok to use but what if you can have
this thing then what is it better it's
better to have a complex mechanism with
abuse business behavior or a simple
mechanism with intractable equilibria
I'm not going to answer this question
but you're invited to our workshop or in
October to study this problem so in
conclusion standard mechanism may not be
implementable when you introduce
computational and communication
constraints and communication and
complex computational complexity provide
tools to study mechanism design under
these considerations and in fact very
beautiful results have come out of
trying to prove interact ability results
for mechanics design the other hand
invasion settings you can bypass a lot
of these lower bounds I mentioned mekin
a general mechanism within the design
reduction with young and mud and also
mention how bayesian setting can be
leveraged to go around to communication
lower bounds and I think there's some
interesting work to be done here because
there are there is this is a singular
result that I know in this setting and
without thanks a lot